I want you guys to remember that, sell, dinner, not marriage.
I want to talk about the objective of this step of calling the business owner directly
and getting them on the hook.
Why do we do this?
Okay, so I want to share a story really briefly.
Back when I was doing door-to-door sales, I saw this thing happen over and over and
over and I saw this happen as I transitioned into selling software and I had salespeople
and I saw it happen in my own life and I've seen it happen with people in this program
already.
Okay, so I want to tell you about this thing.
All right, so guys, going back to when I sold door-to-door, this actually happened with
me first and what happened is I jumped into this door-to-door thing, I got taught a very
basic pitch.
Okay, they said, here's the stats, go knock on the door, here's what you're selling,
I didn't know much about the product, I didn't know much about sales, I didn't know much
in general.
And I started knocking doors and I started saying this basic pitch and what happened
was crazy.
I started selling deals.
I literally started selling deals, I started just doing what they told me and I started
selling deals.
And what happened is after I hit deal number 17, I hit a slump, okay?
I hit a slump where I, what they call bagel, where I didn't sell for two, almost three
days in a row.
And I know some people, it's like, oh, that's not that much.
To me, that was everything because I was so determined I was going to hit this goal.
I had sold 17 deals, I thought I was going to be, I thought I was it, right?
So to not sell for two days in a row after having just moved my family all the way out
to a different state, my pregnant wife, it was scary.
And then day three, I barely snuck in a deal at the end of the day.
And so that happened to me and I've seen this happen to countless reps.
I saw this happen to my center as well, so I'm going to tell you what it is.
What happens to everyone is they get in to a program, to a sales organization, to whatever,
and they take the basic script, if the training is decent, if they're selling a good product,
and they take the basics of the training, okay?
They don't know much about the product, they don't know much about the training, they just
take the basic overview and they start putting in reps.
And the craziest thing happens, they start to get deals, okay?
Happens every time.
I started to get deals doing door-to-door sales.
Some of you guys that are watching this because you're on version 2.0 and you've already seen
version 1.0, you got your first deal doing exactly what I trained and then all of a sudden,
oh my gosh, I'm in a slump, okay?
Here's what happens.
You get in and you're just being simple and to the point and it makes sense.
And then what happens is you start to learn, you start to learn more about the product,
which is our leads, you start to learn more about the sales process, you start to hear
one-liners from me and from other people, and guess what?
You start to over-complicate the process.
And so for me, what ended up happening back when I was doing door-to-door sales is now
I started to know more about the product, I started to know more about the cellular
connection to this panel, okay?
This security system.
Guess what?
Nobody cares, okay?
And I started to use these extra lines in my pitch because I heard managers using them.
So I just started inserting them when they didn't need to be inserted, okay?
And I saw this exact same thing happen to my setter because this is the part where we're
setting the hook.
I saw this happen to my setter literally a year ago.
She came in, I did 44 minutes of training, I had a lick of sales experience, didn't know
anything about our product, I did 44 minutes of training, I gave her a script and she went
out and set, it was between 10 and 12, she hooked 10 to 12 people, literally week one.
And I was like, holy crap, this chick can ball, okay?
And guess what?
A week, maybe 10 days later, maybe it was two weeks, can't remember, she starts to go
into a slump.
She goes from setting 10 to 12 appointments to setting like two.
And she's like, Nick, I don't know what's going on, I was doing well and I've lost my
edge and oh my gosh, it started to affect her confidence.
And then I started saying, okay, start recording yourself, guys, you should be recording everything
you do, okay?
And I said, start recording yourself.
So she started recording herself and I started going in and watching.
Guess what?
She, not her fault, because I didn't tell her this, but she started trying to sell the
deal on the hook, okay?
She started to, during the process when she would call the business owner, this part right
here, she would start getting into too much information.
She started dropping price, she started telling them about the deal structure, she started
them way too much information and as a result, it confused the customer and as a result,
we stopped hooking people.
Telling you right now that this part of the process, the goal is to sell dinner, not marriage,
okay?
We're not trying to get the business owner to buy on this call.
We're not, okay?
These business owners are going to have to go through a series of steps in order for
us to get this deal.
And so, do not try and sell the deal on this call.
All you're trying to do is get them to the next step.
And the next step is to get them to accept a couple of leads in exchange for a conversation.
That is it.
You are not ever going to sell the deal, you're not going to call somebody out of the blue
and then I say you're never, I'm talking 99.9% of the time, okay?
Now I know, someone's going to go, oh I did it this one time.
I'm telling you, if you do that every time, you're going to lose way more deals than you're
going to gain.
The goal is to get them to the next step and the next step is getting them leads.
You are selling dinner, which is the next step, not marriage.
We're not going in the gate, meeting somebody, meeting a guy, meeting a girl, first thing,
boom, let's get married, okay?
Not going to happen.
And if it does, it's the wrong person, okay?
We want this, we want them to go through the steps so that we can overcome their objections,
they can be sold on the process, okay?
So I want you guys to understand that the purpose, the objective here is to get them
to the next step, not to sell them on marriage, not to sell them on this step.
So I'm going to go into more detail in later videos throughout this module.
However, I want to tell you the two most important pieces of information that you want to hold
off for the proper time, okay?
Two pieces.
Now, there's going to be a lot of things, I don't want you guys talking about extra
stuff and talking about SEO and backlinks and this is how we get it and all this stuff.
Keep it simple, okay?
That should go without saying, there's two things I don't want you talking about right
here.
And number one is I don't want you talking about price, okay?
And number two is I don't want you talking about the structure of the deal.
And so what I mean by that is we all know that this is called flat fee mastery.
The goal is, and the only thing we're going to sell is a flat fee deal, but I'm telling
you right now, if on that first call you start telling them, yeah, it's really awesome.
We don't do paper lead.
We don't do commission.
We just do this flat thing where it costs you the same every month, okay?
You might be sold on it.
You might be excited, but if you tell them this at the wrong time without explaining
why properly and at the right time, you're going to lose them.
And all of a sudden you're going to go, oh my gosh, they seem so interested and then
I called them back with some leads and they ghosted me.
It's because you spooked them.
In their heads they hear flat fee and they hear, oh man, that's all the risk.
I don't know this guy.
I don't know this lady.
Like, I don't want to pay a flat fee.
I want to pay commission.
As most of these people, when you initially call them, they're down to do commission,
okay?
And they might be down to do paper lead, but most of them are not comfortable with flat
fee because they don't understand it.
So if you start talking about flat fee from the get, you're going to lose them.
So when they start asking you, because at some point they might start asking you, say,
so how does this work?
Do I pay you per job?
Or, hey, that sounds good.
Let me just pay you per job.
Don't freak out.
Just say, hey, look, I'm not worried about that.
Let me get you a couple of leads and then let's talk.
Again, sell dinner, not marriage, okay?
Same thing when they start asking price.
A lot of these guys or these ladies, when you call them, they're going to say, okay,
so like how much is this going to cost, like whatever?
And I'm telling you, I know that you're going to want to say, oh, it's probably going to
be about a thousand bucks a month.
When you have it in the wrong context, sounds like a ton of money, but a thousand bucks
a month in the right context, explained the right way is nothing.
And that's the way we want to do it.
We want to make sure to show them all the value, show them how much money they're going
to make and then show them price.
But if you do that thousand bucks a month and you compare it to a cell phone, yeah,
it seems expensive, okay?
So my word of advice is this.
If somebody starts asking questions too early about price, about deal structure, okay, or
about anything, but those are the two main ones.
All I want you to do is make it seem like not a big deal and let them know, you know,
let's talk about that later, but let's not put the cart before the horse.
So my go-to is, hey, look, they say, hey, so what's this going to cost or, hey, let
me give you a quick, you know, let me give you a percentage.
Look, hey, honestly, sir, honestly, ma'am, I don't want to put the cart before the horse.
I don't even know if this is going to be a good fit for both of us.
So let me do this.
Let me get you a couple of leads and then we can talk in a couple of days.
And just so you know, I'm very flexible.
I'm very creative.
I'm not worried.
That's the easy part.
Let me just earn your trust and let's make sure this is a good fit and then we can work
this out.
But I'm not that stressed.
Okay.
Heck.
And sometimes I'll even joke like, heck, I'll take food stamps, like, you know, ha ha ha.
Okay.
Guys, sell dinner, not marriage, and just take the pressure off.
You know damn well you're going in for the flat fee deal at a certain price.
You already know that, but you don't need to add added pressure to the deal because
pressure is not something that helps a deal at this point in the deal.
Okay.
So recap, we're selling dinner, not marriage.
Do not share too much information.
And if you're going through this for the first time, you're going to be like, what are you
talking about?
I promise you, you need to know this because at some point you're going to start selling
deals and then you're going to go to what's called a slump and it ain't slump.
You're just sharing too much information.
You're talking out of order.
You're sharing information that needs to be held on until later.
Sell dinner, not marriage.
I'll see you in the next video.